[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist aufgefallen dass ich auf einmal ganz
andere Ziegen habe er sie die kennt ihr
vielleicht noch die Väter aber der
wackelt neu und die anderen sind weg
ich habe nämlich nach einem halben Jahr
verzweifelter Suche endlich ein richtig
schönes Zuhause gefunden für die Ziegen
die immer abgehauen sind und eine Ziege
alleine natürlich total einsam deswegen
habe ich einen Casting gestartet um den
sexy ist ein Ziegenbock überhaupt zu
finden und ich glaube das habe ich auch
geschafft oder mehr liebt das sagst du
bzw Väter was sagst du darf ich
vorstellen das ist Merlin von der
Schanze ich habe jetzt einen Ziegenbock
mit Adelstitel und das heißt auch dass
wir im Frühling dann Zicklein haben
werden und nächstes Jahr wieder merken
können
schau mal wen ich gerade hier erwischt
habe mit einer Nudel aus dem Schnabel
hängt hast keinen essen okay also
vielleicht serki ganz vielleicht musst
du doch in den Käfig gesperrt wenn nicht
trinken
wenn du Sachen machst
[Musik]
wir hatten noch einen sehr schönen Tag
mit Zaki unserem hohen dass mein Kopf
Verstopfung hat und deswegen zu Hause
behandelt wird wir haben sie dreimal am
Tag massiert und dir verschiedene Sachen
zu fressen gegeben weil da gemacht und
so weiter aber wir waren schnell an die
Punkte dass wir gemerkt haben dass wir
so nicht mehr weiter kommen und deswegen
haben wir sacki eingepackt und zum
Tierarzt gebracht und der meinte der
einzige Weg um sie zu retten ist eine OP
und sie hat die OP an sich auch gut
überstanden aber danach beim Tierarzt
dann leider einen Kreislaufzusammenbruch
bekommen und ist dann daran gestorben
und es war total traurig weil wir sie
natürlich vorher schon sehr mochten aber
umso mehr ins Herz geschlossen haben in
den paar Tagen wo sie bei uns gewohnt
hat und ja es tut immer weh wenn ein
Tier geht und wenn es in
Anführungszeichen nur ein Huhn ist das
ist total schade
[Musik]
und Ende November war ich dann mit einem
Freund zusammen in den Schweizer Alpen
Panda an und du hast aber glaublich
[Musik]
ich kann nicht in Worte fassen wie mich
das berührt sieht man das bestimmt
gigantischer direkt dahinter wie ist es
ist so
das weckt so eine Ehrfurcht in mir
ach so angenehm für die Füße
was glaubst du wie unterschiedlich
nehmen wir die Berge war
weil du schon so oft hier
[Gelächter]
bei mir zu Hause
[Musik]
ich wusste nicht dass es solche Farben
gibt dieses orange der Nadeln die hier
überall liegen das ist so unwirklich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das Internet
[Musik]
das sind immer sehr lange Tage für uns
denn wir das Fallobst verarbeiten wir
haben jetzt Apfelmus gemacht Apfel
Quittenmus Quittengelee für den Saft
dann gerade mal ausgerechnet das in
einem kleinen Gläschen
Hagebuttenmarmelade anderthalb Stunden
Arbeit von uns stecken eigentlich sollte
man so gar nicht denken aber das zeigt
doch mal diesen im Nennwert von
Lebensmitteln und wie alt wir diese
Marmelade wertschätzen ist überhaupt
nicht zu vergleichen mit der gleichen
Marmelade die wie aus dem Laden kaufen
würden und ich werde die wieder auch
nicht ansatzweise so gut schmecken
[Musik]